Welcome friends. Whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home,
it's wonderful to connect with you.
Joining us today is Timothy Ernst.
Now, Timothy, for more than three decades,
worked at the intersection of human
resources,
organizational development, leadership
development.
And business strategy, but then he became
fascinated with a question.
Why do some organizations achieve
sustainable
success while others struggle?
Even though all the organizations have
access to similar resources,
technology, and opportunities.
Tim, welcome to Phoenix in Flame.
Thanks for having me, Dana. I really
appreciate it.
This is amazing. Now guys, I I ran across
Tim on LinkedIn because as you know we'll
do and and I'm wanting to support
~ high performers and burnout and and all
the things and so I'm trying
to connect with people. Well what you what
happens on LinkedIn,
for those that don't know, ~ it can be a
fabulous place and sometimes
you run into folks that I don't know,
they're kind of dry. They seem like
they're they have good words.
Good words, ~ good descriptions,
but then when you try to make a connection
and you try to create
a relationship to get something to happen,
there's just there's not a lot there.
~ either they're not interested or to be
brutally honest,
and you know that's what we're like on
Phoenix and Flame,
they're just really boring. Right?
It's just like you fall asleep talking to
them,
all right. So
Tim and I, that's not what happened.
We I I found him on there. I'm like,
my gosh, I love what he was standing for.
I love his his supportive people,
which we're gonna get into all of this.
And then we reached out and we had a
connection call.
And we really we had fun, we laughed,
we we we had a good time and we talked
about stuff that really mattered because
I could tell from Tim, and we're gonna
we're gonna unpack it here,
that he was willing to go there and
address the real things and say the words.
Because I really don't have a lot of
patience for people that aren't willing
to go there and address the real issues.
Cause as a therapist, I hear about these
real issues in my office.
So this is where people really live.
And so if we can't talk about it,
we're wasting time as far as I'm
concerned.
So Tim, I'm very glad to have you on
Phoenix and Flame.
So, you know, I like to create space in
the beginning of the podcast
for my guests to
That's fair.
kind of decide, do you want to start at
the beginning?
Like
Y H R. Or do you have a story you want to
jump right into?
We'll go wherever you want to go.
Well, I like to tell people that I got
into the HR space backwards.
~ I was I I tell the story, I'm one of
these guys that knew exactly what
he wanted to do when he graduated high
school.
You know, I went into college,
jumped into broadcast journalism,
radio and TV news. And by my junior year,
I was going, there has got to be more to
life than dealing with everyone's
tragedies. the the media back then is
definitely not the media that it is today.
~ this whole if it bleeds, it leads
mentality.
It just it it really kind of wore on.
~ I was asked April before May graduation,
~ where I went to the Western Kentucky
University.
They asked me, Hey, do you want to come
back and work on your master's degree?
We feel like you've got a lot of things
that you can teach us.
We still feel like we have things that we
can teach you.
~ and by the way, we'll pay you to teach.
Okay. Hey.
Real life or stay in school. ~ I'll stay
in school.
I very quickly learned why I was there.
I found this class in training and
organizational development.
This is where I say I got into HR
backwards.
I went in through the OD side of things.
~ learned how to connect.
I had used a lot of the knowledge and
skill that I had developed
in the broadcast field, started doing
safety videos,
stuff like that. ~
I ran across Dr. Randy Caps. He was the
head of the Department
of Communication and Broadcasting.
~ he one of his largest customers that he
was working with through
his consulting business was the Lowpool
Corporation.
He asked me if I would work, come and work
for him.
~ he took me under, yes,
Was that whir whirlpool you said?
Okay. Gotcha.
ma'am, the local pool corporation.
Right Randy took me under his wing.
And I I can honestly say that when we look
back at my career.
There are individuals that I can say,
I am where I am because they made me a
better version of me.
Randy really lit that flame. ~ so at
Whirlpool,
after about five years there, moving a
53-year-old manufacturing facility from
a management-based organization and a
team-based organization,
I really got a PhD level education in
human emotion.
And you know how to answer questions,
how to deal with issues. I have this
phrase that I've always said when
it comes to confronting issues.
I'm gonna light my hair on fire,
I'm gonna strip down naked, and I'm gonna
run right through the middle of it.
And I know that that's rather visual and
rather blunt,
Imagery.
but when it comes to confronting issues,
well, when it comes to confronting issues,
you know, I I feel like
People are afraid to I'm gonna say the
wrong thing,
I'm gonna do the wrong thing. And I think
part of that is just because we've become
such a litigious society. but I knew that
if I wanted to keep my hand
in the training and in the OD field,
you know, in this part of the country,
I'm in the Kentucky area, this part of the
country,
you have no choice but to go into the
human resources side of the business.
So I have
Always gone into HR with what I'm going to
say are my eyes wide open.
I look at HR through the lens of
operations.
And I think that that's an important
piece.
~ I'm actually I'm writing a second book
now on leveraging HR as a strategic
partner.
And one of the things that I point out is
HR really needs to have a seat
at the table. Well, how do you get that
seat at the table?
You have to understand how the business
works,
how the business runs, the financial
success.
You have to understand the PL.
~ I'm I'm very fortunate in my career in
that I've had leaders that have said,
go and learn. So, you know, when I was at
Whirlpool,
I would go out and work on the assembly
line.
I stood shoulder to shoulder. I learned
through the eyes of what the
men and women went through on a daily
basis.
When I worked in construction.
I would put steel toe boots on,
my hard hat, hide this vest, I'd jump in a
hole and grab a shovel.
People looked at me like I had two heads.
But for me, it was about seeing it through
their eyes.
You've heard the expression walk a mile in
a man's moccasins.
It's more than that. It's it's truly about
experiencing what they go through
on a day in and day out basis.
And trust me, when you're standing in a
hole in a hole or whether you're moving a
a heavy item that's over a half a million
pounds and you're doing it
in the hot summer in the in the heat or
you're doing it in the winter in the cold,
it gives you a different perspective that
you wouldn't have
So as you're talking,
Right.
I'm thinking of a couple of questions,
and you can take them in whichever order
you would like.
One of them is, how do you think,
and from your experience, how do you
believe that people view HR?
Like employees and and you could you could
go from probably who who
am I talking about? Am I talking about C
suite?
Am I talking about employees? You know,
how from your experience, how has HR been
viewed?
that's one question. And number two,
and they kind of dovetail together.
The question is, what have you experienced
are the pain points
Of being in human resources. You know,
when you go in there,
Yep.
what are the the areas that just they're
just like that that the thorn that just
you can't quite get pulled out of your
side that you've noticed repetitively.
It's not just a one business kind of
situation,
it's it's an HR experience that seems to
go across and and other HR,
you know, people that you've talked to
speak of the same thing.
So those are two different questions,
but they're kind of related.
So I had the privilege of working for a
family road construction business.
They've been around for over 25 years,
helped that organization really to kind of
grow beyond their own expectations,
learned a lot from that family.
And it was while I was there that I really
kind of started
to understand that in my past,
HR was always views, was always viewed as
tactical.
What do I mean by that?
You write the handbooks, you create the
policies,
you do all the hiring, you do all the
firing.
HR was one of those places that you only
went when you either A had a problem
or B were in trouble. I'm not a fan of
that.
~ I always had this philosophy that said,
look, you're gonna have good days,
you're gonna have bad days. I would rather
you come into my office,
shut the door, drop every F bomb under the
sun.
My only request was at the end of that,
say, Tim, thanks for listening.
I feel so much better. Open that door and
leave.
And I will never say another word to you.
I I wanted to create a safe space.
I wanted it to be a place where if people
needed to come and talk,
I could just listen and lend an ear.
~ and I think that's where I think that
viewpoint creates
an issue, meaning that HR is just
tactical.
I think where HR really needs to separate
itself.
And I think in the organizations that have
a very healthy and a very strong culture,
HR is more strategic. ~ and what I mean by
that is,
you know, they're looking at do we have
our ACEs in their places?
You know, from a ~ a longevity
perspective,
when we're looking at turnover,
you know, what are we going to do with
our,
you know, superintendents that have been
there for 30 years that have a
Of experience. Unfortunately, when they
leave,
that knowledge goes with them.
And one of the things that I've tried to
do is,
you know, there's still a lot of value.
~ whether it's creating a training school
or doing training on site,
I'm bringing a lot of those
superintendents in and I'm leveraging
for their leveraging them for their minds
and not for their backs.
Why am I leveraging for them for their
minds?
They've got 30 and 40 years of experience.
I want that knowledge and skill to stay
in-house.
And so what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to duplicate in those employees,
those team members, the knowledge that
that superintendent has.
How great would it be if all of your
leaders were able to,
you know, you were able to duplicate
yourself in five,
six, seven people? That's five,
six, seven people that now have that
knowledge.
You know.
It it's the it's easy to say that if I had
three superintendents and I
put them in front of me, all three of them
would approach a problem differently.
Not a problem with that, especially if
there's no wrong way to solve that
problem.
What if all three of those superintendents
taught seven people how to solve
the same problem? Every one of those
individuals gets a different perspective.
They get to pick the one that really kind
of resonates with them,
their style, their methodology.
And I think again, that's where HR really
needs to go.
That's how HR gets a seat at the table,
it's being more strategic.
You can live in both worlds in HR.
You can be strategic and you can be
tactical.
One of the things that you're going to
find out is that if you're living
on the tactical side all the time,
you're too busy to be strategic.
There's a balance that you have to
carefully walk and carefully take.
Well, and I hear you describing
wonderfully a lot of solutions and
and working with people and trying to help
train so that more people
can know the wisdom and share that around.
Being a therapist, I hear the other side
of things to where you have employees that
they they might be able to come talk.
You mentioned earlier that they would come
in and you might give them
a an amazingly safe place to speak and to
to sh
to share their frustrations. But at some
point,
and I'm sure you would agree, there has to
be change.
Because what I'm what I'm conversations
that I'm hearing is that,
That's where that leadership development
comes from.
yes, I've I've
said all the words. I've they said Dana,
because I'm the queen of boundaries.
And so I'm like, okay, I'm talking to them
and I'm saying it's your responsibility.
If you have a frustration about something,
if you're having an experience at work
that is really annoying you,
frustrating you, if you're being ~ you
know,
taken advantage of by a coworker,
if you feel like you have too much work on
your your plate,
you can't do it all, you're not a robot,
you're you're having panic attacks,
all these things. I said you have to speak
this because
that other people just don't magically
know what you're
Yeah.
thinking and feeling and that's part of
boundaries.
They're telling me, Dana, that sounds
great and it is great.
And I did speak my words and I've spoken
my words for two years
and nothing has changed. So for those
listeners out there or the viewers
on YouTube that might be one of those
individuals that are listening
to this podcast and they're wanting us to
get real.
They're wanting us to
say something that they're experiencing
and thinking how what are they supposed
to do as as an HR expert? Maybe they work
for a business that has an HR department,
maybe it doesn't. And so I'd really like
to know if they work for a place that does
have an HR department, what should they
do?
And what if they work for some place that
it maybe is a smaller hometown business
and they don't have like an HR department,
but
How do they advocate for themselves and
they've talked themselves
to death and nothing is changing?
So, you know, last case scenario is,
hey, you know, I'm I'm not a matcher,
I'm not a fit here. And then what they do
is they find themselves kind
of putting their resume out there and,
you know, they they speak with their feet.
~ you know, a lot of organizations that
I've worked in in the past,
when you look at turnover, ~ for me,
it's okay, why did that turnover occur?
Well, there's a couple of things that I've
generally found.
You know, in some cases, you know,
my manager listens.
That's fine, but does he hear you?
And there is a very big difference between
listening and hearing.
~ you know, listening is just the art of
sound.
You know, that's the shout the sound waves
go into the ear,
they stimulate the facilli, they just you
know,
they go into the cocoa. You know,
when when when when leaders actually hear
you,
they're listening with their mind and
their heart,
you know. ~ but I think in order for
leaders to do that.
There has to be a level of humility there.
~ you know, in psychology, they use this
analogy of kind of peeling the onion.
~ you know, I'm not saying that people
have to know all of your deep dark
secrets.
It's not about that. Number one,
people have to know that people have to
know that just like you,
you make mistakes. And, you know,
one of the things that I've that I've done
is look,
when I make a mistake, I own it.
And if it's a mistake that I've made and
it involves my team.
I talk to my team about it. Hey guys,
this is what I did. This is what I did
long.
This is what I should have done.
~ and here's what I'm doing to try to
correct it.
~ and by doing that, what it does is it it
puts you into that position
of allowing yourself to be human.
~ I'm writing a book right now on ~ I'm
going through and I'm I'm doing
a rewrite on a book on organizational
culture.
And there's five things that I have found
that are kind of interconnected.
~
That really work together to create a
healthy organizational culture.
One of those things is what I call,
you know, daily management systems.
What's a daily management system?
Well, it's the things that happen when
nobody's watching.
It's how do you present yourself?
How do you act? How do you speak?
What words do you choose? You know,
the manner in which you choose to speak
those words.
It's how you represent yourself within
that organization.
It's it's one thing to be one way when
you're in front of a group of people
or if you're an executive around a group
of executives.
But when those executives aren't there,
you know, when you're wearing a company
logo,
you're flying their flag, ~ you're walking
down the hall,
what is that like? It's,
you know, how you know, do you are you out
of character?
If you see something wrong, do you say
something?
The manner in which you say it,
do you lose your temper, raise your voice?
Do you demand things? I don't I don't do
that.
You know, I have conversations with
people.
I ask. I set some expectations.
But I don't set expectations that I'm not
willing to follow myself.
And I think that's one of the big
differentiators that we're seeing
in business today is that, you know,
since COVID.
~ I saw this early even pre-COVID,
but since COVID seems to have gotten
worse.
You know, organizations have become
scattered.
You know, you see more and more people
working from home.
This is this camera and and their
computer.
It's kind of how they connect with people.
And I think it's harder for leaders today
to be able to keep that camaraderie
~ with their team when this is the method
that they have.
~
I was talking to a manager the other day
and I made the comment.
I said, understand you're managing people
virtually.
How many times do you have a check a just
check-in just to see how they're doing,
how they're working, how things are going?
Do they need anything? It's it's one of
those calls that you make that basically
says, look.
You're what's going on with you is more
important right now.
How can I help you? ~ he goes,
I never do that. He said, I'll bet if you
start doing it the first time you do it,
you're gonna raise an eyebrow.
What's what are they up to? The second
time you do it,
Yeah. Alter motive. What do they want?
~
yeah, exactly.
Well, it's it's you haven't established
trust.
That's the key. You have
Mm-hmm.
to have that trust there. ~
And I think the second time you do it,
the third time that you do it,
the fourth time you do it with intent,
people start to see, hey,
they really are trying to connect.
They really are trying to be different.
They really are trying to make me feel
like I'm part of a a bigger process.
And and honestly, I think
Well, and I I don't
that's the thing that's missing.
the and I don't have the statistics with
me right at at at the table,
but statistics show that people will
tolerate
quite a bit of of unrest, of upset if they
feel like they are connected,
if they feel like they belong.
And one of the things that we had talked
about before was that when people start
to get burnt out
They disengage. They they like they pull
away.
I feel in my mind I see it like two train
cars on a track and they just decouple.
They just just start moving apart.
They're not connected.
There's a term there's a term
for that now that they use in business.
It's called quiet quitting. It's people
Yes.
that they're still there, they're still
occupying a space.
They've quit on the job, they just forgot
to tell you.
So by not having or establishing trust
early on,
that's what happens. You know,
you make a great point, Dana. ~ team
members will stay and put up with more
when
They feel like they're a part of the
process when they feel like that
the organization has their best interest
in part,
or the organization is going to help them
grow and develop.
If they're just kind of, if they just feel
like,
hey, the only reason I'm here is to do ABC
XYZ,
I come in, I go home, I collect a
paycheck.
I come in, I go home, I collect the
There's nothing else for me, they're going
to start looking.
You know, if you want to know.
how strong your culture is. What's your
turnover like?
And it's not just turnover, but how many
key employees
or high potential employees that you've
identified are leaving.
And I think if you start to identify,
you know, where those high potentials are
and the turnover at that level,
it's going to say a lot about your
culture.
Well, and see, that's amazing.
It and it's so true. And I'm wondering
what how you see the role of
HR in helping the leaders see what's going
on because
I see a scenario where sometimes the
leaders are allowing the team members
to become overwhelmed. They there's like a
layoff
by attrition going on and and they're
they're getting more and more things
put on their plate and they're told just
Just figure it out, right? And and
Do more with mass.
people can do that to a point.
You know, you have amazing people and they
will take on more.
They'll figure out how to work smarter,
not harder. They and that's an you know,
you put them in a a vice like that.
And some people are amazing at what they
come out,
but everybody has a limit because we are
not cyborgs.
We are human beings. And so I'm wondering.
what you see the role of HR in helping
leaders to not because it i
if these people get burned out and they
quit then it costs a
lot of money research indicates that it it
takes ~ about five like if if
you have a a a a like an intermediate
level ~ corporation about
a thousand employees it costs them
approximately five million dollars a year
to restaff and retrain employees because
they've left because they're burnt out,
they're overwhelmed, they don't feel hurt,
they don't feel connected. So what do you
see?
Because I know right now as we're talking,
the people that are listening to this
podcast right now,
there's going to be a percentage of them
that are walking this path right now.
They might be at work on lunch break.
They might be, you know, they might be
listening to the podcast on the way home.
They might be walking on a weekend and
their their life is this
and they're they're frustrated.
I'm wondering what you see as the HR
department and also if there's
not a department, if they're working for a
place that's there's not a department,
what they can do, you know, what do you
say?
How do you train, how do you communicate
with the leaders so that they don't
end up leaving? Because that costs more
money.
Yeah. I think so let let's start with your
first question.
So what role can HR play? You know,
for me, you know, I work with leaders all
the time.
And it's it's funny when you work in the
construction industry or in
the heavy hall industry where I'm at now,
you know, you always think of of leaders,
foreman, superintendents as being these
these these gruff guys.
You know, I have never worked around a
group of people that really
had the the desire to do the right thing.
But at the same time, they're just so
conflict avoidant.
And part of that is the fact that,
you know, when they were brought into this
profession,
or they were, you know, when they grew up
into this profession,
you know, typically you look and it was
their grandfather did it,
their father did it. So this is kind of
one of those things that it's passed
on as a generation. And, you know,
even my generation, I'm a Gen Xer by
birth.
You know, we were taught to rub dirt in
it,
don't cry, get over it. And,
you know, I think today,
You know, it's no, you've you've got to
understand that look,
when you're talking about people,
the entire package means that emotions are
going to be involved.
That that's part of being human.
So we're not cybers. You know,
if when I work with my team or when I work
with new leaders,
what I always do is it's like,
okay, you have to get work done as a
leader.
Your team helps you to get that work done.
My recommendation is listen,
guys.
Here's what I need. Here's by when I need
it.
How you get it there is totally up to you.
I'm available if you have questions.
I'm available if if you get stuck or you
need somebody to support or
you want to bounce some questions off of
me.
And then I think what we do is you allow
people to bring their strengths
to the table. Now, if you're a leader and
you've got a crew that's established
and you you understand or you know how
that crew works.
You give them assignments that allow them
to play into those strengths.
If you have an employee who says,
look, I really want to grow, okay,
let's talk about that. Let's talk about
what growth looks like.
And then I might give them tasks that are
stretch assignments.
Maybe it's just something they've never
really done before.
I'm going to give them a chance to try it.
And then we're going to use that as a
coaching opportunity.
Sit down with them. Hey.
Here's the things that you did that were
absolutely spot on fantastic.
I noticed you struggled here. Let's talk a
little bit about that.
Now let me share with you why where I
struggled when I first started doing this
and why. And let me tell you some things
that I did to kind of work through that.
So again, I go back to be human,
peel that onion, share your successes,
share your failures. People are not
robots.
But I think if you can assign tasks that
play into people's strengths.
I think you're gonna win it. I mean,
you're gonna win. You're you are going to
win,
but in order to play into their strengths,
you've got to get to know your people.
There's no other way around that.
You had a second question in there,
and it's kind of a you know, what happens
if you're ~ in a smaller organization
and you don't have HR and you really need
to talk to your manager?
This is where I'm gonna ask the question
Can you take a risk?
Why that question? Well
When I go in and I talk to my manager,
it's about, hey, this is what I'm doing
today.
This is where I see my path. This is the
direction that I'm going.
How does that align with your vision for
me?
~ and then what are some things that we
can do together collectively
to ensure that I'm going from A to B,
B to C, C to D?
And and maybe that path that I have
envisioned for myself is a little
bit different than the path that my
manager has envisioned for me.
You're never going to know that until you
take that risk and ask the question.
I like that. And that really that aligns
right with the whole the
way I teach boundaries is that I I teach
it in terms of yards.
In our yard are our thoughts, feelings,
and actions. And then there's a property
line and our neighbors' thoughts,
feelings, and actions are in their yard,
and we're not responsible for those.
But we do have a responsibility for our
own and to present those to people
in a respectful way. And so when we know
that,
then that's that's a fabulous thing.
Now, I wanted to ask before we finish
today,
I wanted to get your take on,
because you're you're you know,
you're focusing on people like you you had
something in your bio about whether it's
growth, innovation, customer service,
leadership or culture, all of that
requires people.
that your emphasis has been on supporting
people,
supporting the person. And organizations
grow when people grow.
And so you've really you've really
championed the person,
right? So I'm wondering how you have seen
and how
you anticipate AI impacting
the person's experience at work and what
they are
anticipating what might be coming down the
pike and how that might impact their
you know, what they're thinking's gonna
happen and the fears and all the stuff.
So, Dana, I'm going to say, I think you're
probably reading my mind.
You started asking that question,
and I had this devilish grin on my face.
Why? Why would I have
Yes, you did, I saw it.
that devilish grin on my face?
Let me answer that question with another
question.
You know, when organizations say,
you know, we want to grow, we want to be
more profitable,
we want to expand our offerings,
we want to increase production,
you know, we want to build faster.
How are we going to do that? The answer is
simple.
People. Bottom line, everything every
organization wants to do involves people.
Okay, so AI is,
you know, I read all these articles where
AI is going to replace this
and AI is going replace that. To some
degree,
yes, I think it will. However,
AI is a tool.
AI will go out, it will scour the
internet,
it will gather all of the information.
But it still takes people to be able to
translate what AI has produced.
AI is never going to put in a footer,
dig a foundation, raise a building.
AI might teach you a smarter way to do it,
but it still takes people to be able to
execute that.
You know, in manufacturing, you know,
you've got all these.
Kanban systems, push, pull, and all these,
or it's it's it's all based on inventory.
And is it just in time? Is it this?
Is it that? You know, AI may be able to
sharpen that to where you don't have
so much inventory on hand. Because when
you look at manufacturing,
if you go to like a small parts warehouse
or you go to a warehouse where they have
items stored, you know, that makes
accountants sweat.
The reason it makes accountants sweat is
That's money sitting there. And if that
money
Mm-hmm.
is not on a dryer or on a car or on
whatever that you're building,
it's a cost. You don't recoup that cost
until it goes on to whatever
it is that's going out. And then you don't
recoup that cost until you sell it.
That's how that wheel works. AI might make
you better.
at how you can run your small parts
warehouse because you can take all this
data
and throw it into AI. And AI is absolutely
phenomenal with crunching
complex data. But at the end of the day,
it still takes people to be able to
execute.
Yeah. That you got I mean, your points are
are spot on.
And I I have an example to to to ~ support
what you just said.
I'm a podcaster, obviously, and people
will approach me wanting to guest
on my podcast. Well, what AI has done is
it's given some interesting individuals
a way to communicate themselves,
~
through like with on on email like
messaging and they appear
one way they appear like if I just go off
their message I'd be like my gosh this
is amazing right but once I dig in and
find the profile I find the person
I listen to you know their podcast
episodes and this kind of stuff I find
out that who the person is
Their personality, the the the way they
are,
how they appear on on a podcast is very
different than what was represented
to me on the message because because they
were using an AI tool.
So it's it can be used as a tool,
but you still at at some point you're
gonna be person to person.
And you have to really watch out for that.
In about 90 days, I'll have a book.
In about 90 days, I'll have a book that's
going to be available.
It's called Systems Over Slogans:
How Leaders Build Cultures That Perform,
Adapt, and Endure. And this is really kind
of through the lens of,
hey, look, I've been in this industry for
for 30 years.
You know, these are some things that I've
seen.
And I've got stories throughout the book.
And I always tell people that,
you know, the names were changed to
protect the guilt.
Unfortunately, you also have to change the
names to protect the good people as well,
because you just you never know how people
are going to react to it.
Well, you know, a lot of this is stuff
that it's my experience,
it's stuff that I've written. It's a lot
of the stuff that we're talking about here
today. And, you know, I was playing around
one day and I was like,
if I dropped this into Chat GPT,
how it would make it pretty. And it it
did.
It made it pretty and made it me.
It wasn't my voice. It wasn't me.
And you know, that's where I go back to
your original question about AI is
AI is a great tool. If you want to write
an email,
man, it can write a flowery email.
Sounds professionally written,
but does it have your voice? You know,
can it help you solve problems?
It can. But you still have to execute.
AI cannot execute for you. You have to do
that yourself.
~
You know, it's it's it's it's a great
tool.
~ you know, it's like your Outlook
calendar,
it's like your email, it's like,
you know, your iPhone, Android,
if you're an Android user. You know,
all of these things have a place.
All of these things are tools.
They all help us become better,
stronger, faster versions of ourselves.
But at the end of the day, this iPhone,
it's an inanimate optic. It's just gonna
sit there until I pick it up.
I push buttons, I do with it what I need
to do.
AI is no different.
That this is this has been such a
interesting conversation and I know,
you know, there's people listening that
thinking I'm I'm walking that,
I'm experiencing that. And you mentioned a
couple of books.
So I wanna make sure that people that are
listening and watching,
how Tim, how do they where do they find
the books?
Where do they go?
So right now I'm going through rewrites.
So they're not out there, they're not
publicly available.
Like I said, in about the next 90 days,
systems over slogans, how leaders build
cultures that perform,
adapt, and endure ~ should be available.
My goal is to try to get this thing
published sometime towards the end of
summer,
beginning of fall. ~ I started writing a
second book on HR as a strategic partner.
~ I'm about halfway through that book.
I think that that book realistically
probably won't be ready until next year.
and the reason that I say that is when you
do a rewrite,
you know, all of my spare time right now
is really spent focusing on making this
the best version that it can be.
~ and ~ one of the things that I'm doing,
Dana, one of the reasons that I'm being so
meticulous and so methodical with this
is I've been blessed. I have stood on the
shoulders of giants.
I am where I am today because people took
a chance on me.
I didn't write a book.
Because you know, I'm looking for fame and
fortune.
I wrote a book because I had this
knowledge that I gained
and that I through trial and error,
you know, I I've worked with. I really
wanted to get this out there to
be able to share it with executives,
with HR practitioners, with those folks
that really want to make
a difference in their organization.
~ I'll tell you like I've told other
people,
when this thing is ready, my social media
is going to light up because
I'm gonna put it out there. I'm gonna
stand on the highest mountain.
~ I'll even reach out to you, Dana,
let me know, hey, this thing is available.
Here it is. ~ because, you know,
again, this is something that I really
want to be able to share with you.
So let me ask you, and I know our time is
up and we've gone a little bit over,
but that's okay. It's my podcast.
I can do that if I want to.
I think
So, here's my last question to you about
your book.
I imagine there's a lot of books out there
about HR.
Why would someone why should they pick
yours?
What is gonna make your book be any
different than all the other HR books
out there that cover all the the fancy
words and the
You know, the multisyllabic words,
da da da da da. Why why should they pick
yours?
Well, systems over slogans, the book on
culture,
really kind of highlights, you know,
it's all the things that we talk about in
an organization,
you know, the importance of communication,
the importance of having a healthy
mission,
vision, and values, and how you use that
as the lens for how you make decisions.
I worked with a great construction
company.
And not only did they have a mission and
core value statements posted on their
wall.
Every meeting we talked about it.
It was in action. We closed meetings with
it.
We lived it. We breathed it. It was the
lens through which we did what we did.
~ and that's an example of of how you use
that stuff.
You know, it was interesting because I I
reached out to several people that have
influenced me and I said, Hey,
would you mind reading this? Tell me what
you think.
And ~ I got feedbacks ~ from Molly.
Molly said, Hey, this is great,
you know, you you you
You kind of skirted the issue,
but you didn't really talk about it.
And that's conflict. And I'm like,
my God, you're right. Healthy
organizations,
conflict is okay. You have to have that in
a healthy organization.
But how you manage that is ~ important.
And so there's chapter seven is just all
on conflict.
We talk about generational differences.
~ and then the other thing that we talk
about,
there's these five.
Systems that you'll hear me refer to.
I've already kind of talked about one of
them daily management.
~ recruitment systems, promotion systems,
onboarding systems, and then performance
systems.
All five of those kind of work like a ~
Hmm.
a cog. And when all the wheels connect and
all of the wheels turn,
the machine works beautifully.
But at the bottom, what makes all this
stuff go?
People, not AI.
like that people that's it we definitely
are aligned with that people
are the that that they're what makes
everything go around Tim thank you
so much for sharing your time and your
wisdom and your experience with myself
and Phoenix and Flame listeners and
viewers today.
Thank you very, very much.
David, thanks for having me. I really
appreciate it.
Hey guys, I know you've heard multiple
things today that you're thinking,
you know what? I have a friend,
I have a coworker, I have a relative that
really needs to hear this conversation
between Dana and Tim. Take this episode,
copy and paste it in text, copy and paste
it,
send an email, post it on your favorite
social media sites so we
can grow our Phoenix inflame community and
let people know you are not alone.
I'm Dana.
I hope you've had a great day.
I hope the rest of your day is fantastic.
This is Phoenix in Flame.